it's valentine's day uh uh oh look at
that
oh yes
gets my heart every year i've i read the
most touching story this year about how
two gen z's are celebrating together
well not together uh because they're
afraid to go out with the virus but um
but they sent beautiful cards well not
cards uh one texted a heart emoji
another one texted back same
so it's a beautiful story
but here's something i don't understand
43 i read this in a survey of singles
now saying that we should uh expand
valentine's day to include the concept
of self-love
[Laughter]
does everything have to come around to
be the opposite of what it [ __ ] is
nothing more
nothing more romantic than a candlelight
dinner over the sink
but
but i uh i am gonna end unhappy not here
tonight if it kills me
no i have one donald trump for the first
time is way down with republicans
like women republicans men republicans
republicans without white guys without
college degrees his base
well i'm talking about 20 points down
this is very big good news
and we found
out a new book says that when he was
president he used to routinely flush
wads of paper
down the toilet
[Laughter]
and also i
think he used to take a [ __ ] in the
document shredder he may just have it
but
it looks like he may have been trying to
hide things then you know when you're
president you're supposed to when you
leave turn over all the papers to the
national ark archives
right trump took them with him to
mar-a-lago
[Music]
he wanted them including the letter
remember the love letters with kim
jong-un
the letters that said thing
kim called him your excellency
kim said our our friendship will be like
a magical force he said our
next meeting is it gonna be like a
fantasy film
really that was in this letter now you
may ask yourself what kind of idiot
would fall for that kind of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i say again trump took them with him to
mar-a-lago
and
not
not just that 15 boxes
that's
this is the people's property that he
took with him that you're not supposed
to take including the love letters and
the remember the hurricane map that he
drew on with the sharpie
well whatever it is it's the people's
property and now it's going to the
smithsonian so the future
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the weakest virtue signaling i've seen
all week but okay
but yes this way future historians can
look at it and go what the [ __ ]
you